if it has a penis it's probably about
sex it's when someone texts you late at
night and they say you look because they
looking for the goods what are the good
the sex goods they want to sleep with
you but not in the conventional sleep
more like that okay look I have never
sent one of these because I'm a
gentleman
you guys ever received or sent you up
texts I plead the fifth I think so yeah
there's some there's a couple times I've
left a bar I normally send those I don't
receive them no I've never said you up
sometimes the night's get cold nights
get lonely you got a check to see if
your wife is up because if she's awake
then you know you might be able to watch
TV with her dudes just like one he's not
creative I might have said you hook text
once or twice on my life and how would
you just ask them about their day how
would you ask about how things going on
did it work um
no can I stop sending them we got to do
better people oh I always do why I owe
you
because I keep it classy you'll have to
spell out you in any context I don't
associate with people who only use the
letter just you got to keep it real I do
put in yo cuz I would like to keep it
informal keep it hip you get a text late
at night
it says you up I mean somebody want to
get them goods and then goods be all the
good things you have to offer I'm not
gonna impose how you have sex upon you
maybe a door maybe a bath nothing else